e3 2021 has come and gone it showed us
some stuff we expected to see
some new reveals and a whole lot of cool
looking indies too
but there was also a whole lot of games
missing that i think a lot of us were
expecting to see
so here's a roundup of e3 2021's games
gone missing let us know what you are
hoping to see in the comments
and while you're at it make sure you're
subscribed to our channel to stay up to
date on all the latest
on gaming
[Music]
huh
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
quiet shut
they up ascent run
just keep running
are you out of your mind he's not going
to make it
he has to bless that correct
my eternal life protects me
look at me all the gold we want
is right there
oh i i just came here for
get over knowledge no breach the seal
get us through that door
[Applause]
opens blood
shows this doesn't make any sense
blood plus blood is the key
blood is the king what i need two of you
no go i'll hold them go
so it says the blood of the willing
goes you gotta be kidding me
i walked
we have to help him he's dead already
as shamey didn't make it
oh well cheer up gold splits better
three ways instead of four
must be hidden here
read this
but by three they come by three thy way
opens by the blood of them
willing hail
hail the the creator
hail the daughter oh no
no no no what about the coin what's it
say
this is forbidden this is a summoning
i cannot speak don't lie to me we came
here
for treasure what is this place
i i don't know maybe
maybe it's a temple oh god two more
oh
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
by three
[Music]
[Music]
we call them
there is no light here
you came to the darkness for knowledge
yes and all the knowledge you seek
is here surrender
speak the words
call her home
by three they come
[Music]
by three thy way opens
by the blood of the willing
we call thee home
[Music]
hey daughter
of hatred
creator
of sanctuary
hey
[Music]
lilith
[Music]
[Music]
blessed mother
save us
[Music]
will you follow me
[Music]
on this journey
[Music]
by sea
[Music]
by land
and dreams through the valleys of
despair
over the mountains of rage to the depths
of fear
in my mind you might see me as
weak but i
will show you what lies behind my eyes
with our sword
we will forge new stories
to strike the gods that haunt us
we will embrace our suffering
soothe our scars of grief
and break their siege of our minds
they may see them as gods
but we
we will show them what lies behind our
eyes
in this nyotaro
where's your master i don't deal with
domesticated
hey the [ __ ] i ain't got no master but i
do have
your little toy
show me the idol show me the redeemer
here you go mate
[Music]
yo yo yo hand it over i got a hot date
don't do late
monkey's got a date
what what what what
that swiss [ __ ] chocolate pig
[Music]
i want every
[Music]
[Music]
grab my chassis
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] me
damn right
breaking news
[Music]
so
[Applause]
it's about bloody time
let's see what we've got
[Music]
true freedom lies beyond
[Music]
[Music]
men from all over the world sail the
territories trade routes of the indian
ocean
the riches in their homes fuel their
dreams of
power and fortune while wetting the
appetites of those they fear most
[Music]
pirates
that what he goes therefore
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
fire
[Music]
miracles
[Music]
i'm never gonna survive
[Music]
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
lips
[Music]
[Music]
give me
i'm going in
is taking heavy fire get to park ridge
asap
don't worry boss we got this hey
boomer lay down suppress and fire
keep it down these are still ringing
after that last barney
what is that australian for hangover
i believe i can translate boomerang has
a concussion
from the enemy you missed in our last
encounter
i guess those teeth are sharper than
your eyes shark man
i never never missed never miss yeah
yeah we bloody no you never shut up
about it
smooth well
that should knock a few years off the
old sentence that's
reminding me of something
oh yeah waller's stupid alpha target
[Music]
oh look it's superman
the mighty superman has just rescued
that pilot
[Music]
we're on a top spandex assassination
mission here
no no
so figure out who we're killing yet
oh no did you ever think i felt like a
microphone like that there but we still
stay free big things happen every time
we meet like a track
right now i shouldn't have done that
shock
[Music]
magic both beautiful and powerful
binds together our long history
that common bond we share is the legacy
of hogwarts
now it is time to add your own story to
these hallowed walls
and quite possibly shape the future
of the wizarding world
every corridor every portrait
every stone in this castle tells the
story
witches and wizards who came before
here you will meet lifelong friends and
grow into your
own magical abilities in the classrooms
of the world's most
talented professors and
while your journey begins at hogwarts
brewing potions
taming fantastic beasts
and mastery spells
there is a larger world beyond these
walls
a world filled with dangers you can't
yet
imagine an ancient knowledge
long gone from this world
that strange and mysterious talent you
possess
may be the key to unlocking this
dormant power
your potential
is limitless
[Music]
but what form will it take
the journey ahead will reveal
what you stand for
[Music]
the choices you make now
will define the legacy of hogwarts
[Music]
in breaking news we've received reports
of an explosion
somewhere north of the city we're still
waiting for the police to confirm
if there are any victims this story is
evolving rapidly
please bear with us really loud boom
there was smoke
and emergency services have confirmed
that they've discovered a body buried in
the wreckage
we're still waiting for further details
that a large portion of the building has
actually collapsed international news
an explosion rocked gotham city earlier
you're now able to confirm that
billionaire philanthropist
bruce wayne is
if you're watching this i'm dead
this is a cold black
this message was automatically triggered
when i destroyed the cave and everything
it contained
we both know it won't take long for
gotham's criminals to realize the batman
is gone
and he can't count on the gcpd haven't
trusted us since jim died
gotham will need its protectors more
than ever
[Music]
i'm leaving you the belfry as base of
operations
some of the technology is outdated but
it has the gear you need and all of my
files
you've always had my back when i needed
you i know you'll keep gotham safe
good luck and goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
no one talks about them
[Music]
not a whisper word is said
for if you try to crush them
then natalie
strikes you dead
most people think time is like a river
that flows swift and sure in one
direction
but i have seen the face of time
and i can tell you
they are wrong
[Music]
inside the hourglass is a marvel no
living man has ever seen
only the dagger can unlock the sands of
time
[Music]
you cannot defeat this enemy the sands
will consume
everything come with me then but i warn
you i move pretty fast
you'd better keep up
the dagger it can turn back
[Applause]
[Music]
give me the dagger never
[Music]
[Music]
i brought this on us you are brave
[Music]
you all know the target shiva's dominant
and only the dominant
how do we even know the girl will be
among them
our kind do not question orders we
follow them
sergeant let's summon their icon
i can't that thing's a bloody mountain
our foe will not relinquish their mother
crystal easily
this will be a bitter fight
you should not be out of doors we have
discussed this
come joshua your father will be
expecting us
i am joshua's shield
i'm sworn to protection
[Music]
what do you mean you refuse did you not
pledge your sword to our cause
what does it matter it was the dull
necks who drove back the crusaders in
the battle of the twin realms
without the blessing of the mother
crystal we cannot defend our realm from
the spread of the black
imperial vipers do they really mean to
invade us
it's the archduke's son
felix
that's impossible
the legacy of the crystals
has shaped our history
so long enough
[Music]
i'll kill you
if it's the last thing i do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
what is that
freedom our freedom
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
the world is filled with stories
of legendary heroes
and treacherous villains
[Music]
of fantastical creatures
and wondrous places
where nature and magic
live in perfect harmony
not all stories have happy endings
but yours has yet to be written
[Music]
[Music]
come
coming up
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
good
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
we have always known war
it forged our empire
turned heroes into queens and kings
and decimated our foes
[Music]
now our oaths are lost
forsaken
and you must face the monsters
[Music]
our sins have borne
is an oath worth the weight of a crown
[Music]
i remember when everything changed
the floods the storms
the fires people dying
in the streets
the corporations gave us solutions
[Music]
a better world
[Music]
and we welcome them into our lives
but the laws of nature aren't meant
to be broken we need to know what
they're hiding
[Music]
[Music]
did you find the answers you were
looking for
agent dark not yet
this is just the beginning
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ugh
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
hey man get up
[Applause]
[Music]
are you seeing this something ain't
[Applause]
right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is black iris to transport should
care on
you are cleared for landing
[Music]
you see things others can't
hear threats others don't
fight when others won't
it's up to you to save tokyo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hide is that a [ __ ] dragon
is it gone yes and we should leave this
place as well
why that thing out there
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
he leaves us no recourse swords
never s frost will answer for its crimes
today
are these the wages of loyalty raised
earth and burnt corpses
you and no other must decide how we
proceed
[Music]
you are a leader and must be the beacon
others look to when the night is darkest
together with these fields today you
burn i promise to do all in my power to
see us through this safely
every last one of us
far far away lies the continent of
nausilia
comprised of three nations and limited
deposits of salt
and iron the constant feuds among the
nations over these precious resources
eventually ignited into a great conflict
known as the salt iron war though the
hostilities ceased with an uneasy truce
decades later the flames of war
threatened to engulf the realm
once again you are all that remains
caught in a tangled fiery web of plots
and conspiracies
a brave group from glenbrook fights to
save their kingdom
from the powers that would orchestrate
their downfall
our benefit you say
[Music]
in this new tactical rpg battles take
place on terrain with different
elevations
a character's attack range is determined
by their location and their equipped
weapon
the range can be extended by attacking
from higher ground with long range
weapons
such as bows and arrows thus your forces
can use the terrain and other elements
to gain the upper hand an enemy
outflanked is susceptible not only to
your initial attack but also a powerful
blow from the ally positioned behind the
enemy
what have we here
charge into an enemy to send them flying
into position for a follow-up attack
we wish link attacks together by first
casting ice magic on the flames to
create
water terrain then electrify the area
with lightning magic
it is of the utmost importance to survey
the battlefield
before taking action
[Music]
throughout the story you will be faced
with making important decisions
in a variety of situations
morality liberty collectively
your decisions will establish your
conviction
affecting how the story unfolds and who
will join your cause
once more i would ask you plainly do we
or don't we
relinquish prince roland to estrust
critical decisions that may determine
the fates of nations
are settled by vote on the scales of
conviction
use information you've gathered to sway
allies toward your favorite cause
the story will significantly change
based on how the votes are cast
so they refuse to relinquish him to us
lies
his hand was forced as more and more
critical decisions are made
your journey may take you down paths
divergent
from those of other players you will see
what true
might is
project triangle strategy a brand new
tactical rpg from square enix
will launch in 2022 please be on the
lookout for more information
in the future after this presentation
a demo version of this game will be
available to download on nintendo eshop
and in the future we'll conduct a survey
to gather player feedback
we look forward to hearing your
responses on the demo
[Music]
our world has a rhythm
we all sense it
[Music]
but only a few truly feel it
it is found in the smallest moments
in every step of a perilous journey
in the symmetry of ritual
[Music]
in the bonds we share
and in moments of stillness
[Music]
it teaches us to look beyond the
expected
to be a light in dark places
to seek answers
and to stand watch over our world
our world has a rhythm
we all sense it
[Music]
but only a few truly feel it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
thanks for watching make sure to like
and subscribe for more gaming coverage
and videos like this one
you